こんにちははじめしゃちょーです
皆さんはホテルとか宿泊施設泊まったこと
ありますでしょうか
桐月さんありますかあります
嘘つけいろんな
ホテルとか宿泊施設とかあると思うんです
けども
世の中には
変わった宿泊施設だったりホテルという
ものが存在するみたいなので今回なんか
色々見てたら
ホテル
変なホテルってのがあったんですよ僕
あんまり情報入れずに来てしまったので
何かわからないんですけどもパッと見
なんかすごい
不思議な感じでしたというわけで早速その
変なホテルの名前どんなホテルなのか
ちょっとこちらに考えるので見てみたいと
思いますこちら
変なホテルです
そのままなんですよ何もひねってなくて
マジで変なホテルっていう名前のホテルで
もう建物も見た感じねそんな
外観は変ではないですよね
普通じゃない
超普通ねシンプルなホテルって感じなん
ですけどちょっと何が変なのか全くわかん
ないんで早速行ってみたいと思いますいき
ましょう
ちょっと
もう入り口からやばいよ
入り口からやばいです
ね今こうやって中入ろうと思ったんですよ
こうやってきたら
このスタッフですか
結構動きやばいけどねこれスタッフで
間違いないですか
確認しに行ってみましょうかそうですね
行きましょうかいやー
じゃあ行きませんのホテル
失礼します
ヘンというか
恐竜だね
いやすげーすごいなめっちゃ動くして歯怖
変なホテルだねフロントにこれは多分
なかなかないと思いますけどもそこが多分
チェックインかな
あー
本日
[音楽]
ですね
わかりました
はいありがとうございます
じゃあ早速ホテル行きましょうか
もう行くか
エレベーターはまあまあまあまあ結構普通
ですね
我々6階ですちょっとでもなんか今パッと
見たんだけど
変わり続けるホテルって書いてあったんだ
よだから多分今はそういう恐竜
テーマなホテルの可能性はあるなるほど
着きました行きましょう
こっちかな
普通のホテルではね今のところ
変なホテルどころがいいホテルぐらいの
感じではあるけど
はいここが今日の
景色と俺の愛の巣になりますありがとう
ございます行きます
[音楽]
失礼します
僕の名前はこの
部屋のコンシェルジュだよ今日という日が
特別になるように
僕が全力でサポートするよ
ありがとう
ホテルのことで知りたいことがあったら
例えば
朝ごはんは何時まで
みたいに
奥に話しかけてね
他にもお部屋の電気をつけたり歌ったり
踊ったりできるよ
今からダンスを踊るから見ててね
結構です
[音楽]
これからよろしくねよろしく
焼きそばパン買ってきて
普通に
首振られたけど横にお前
ダンスをしたいのない
照明を消して
[音楽]
まず
照明
[音楽]
ちゃんと仕事しろ逆に今ついてないのかも
しれないからねちょっとつけてみようって
みよう少年をつけて
照明つけるねうんそう
明るくなったね
ってことはよ照明を消して
うん照明ですね
せーの
全然性能の前に消したやん
すごいね
結構俺言葉ゴ持ってると聞き取りづらいっ
て言われるけどしっかり聞いてくれるの
健介の婚期はいつ
[音楽]
無理です
以外にも
クイズやしりとりも
適応への説明書を見てね
チェスケもしりとりできるよ
[音楽]
テレビをつけて
わかった
はい
おーすごいねー
[音楽]
じゃない
ぐるっと見ようとしてみる
端っこから今
撮影してんなこっちは
そんな時間だ
いやいいから
撮影してるから
お前自分勝手だな電源オフで
変なホテルのお部屋に入りました全然いい
感じのねしっかりしたホテルなんですけど
もなんかロボがいるみたいだねちょっと
色々回ってみましょうかこんなホテル
すごいのが舞浜にありまして
近くにディズニーランドディズニーシーが
あるという
リッチがめちゃくちゃすごいよね
本当ベッドも普通に2つあってここがなん
か洗面台かあれ
ゴリラが取ろうもっとおいおいおいおい
おい誰がロボコンじゃんはいというわけで
本当に変なホテルですねもういろんな
場所が変というかもう何が起きるかわかん
ないんですけども
早速このお部屋そしてこのホテルで原付と
一晩過ごしていきたいと思います何が
起きるか分かりません早速ホテル夜ご飯
食べていきたいと思いますここにあユーロ
食べれないんだここには夜ご飯はあじゃあ
外食べていきましょうか
美味しそうだね
[音楽]